I'm standing up and I'm telling you I am
Warhol I am the number one most
impactful artist of our generation I am
Shakespeare in the flesh what Disney
Nike Google now who's gonna be the
Medici family and stand up and let me
create more or do you want to
marginalize me till I'm out of my moment
or why don't you empower yourself and
don't need them and do it yourself
hats wait take a few steps back to get
the answers man you only got the answers
and you ain't got the edges you already
got the answers wait I've been doing
this morning you doing we got you ain't
got the answers you ain't got the
answers you ain't been doing the
education bro you ain't been doing an
education you don't have the answers
don't because you're trying to give me
advice about something
you ain't got that you ain't spent 13
million dollars a year on money trying
to empower yourself but I spent hundreds
of thousands and don't put now clothing
lines at a smaller degree all I'm asking
you and there ain't no Ralph though
what's the name of your clothing line we
don't know exactly and I could lose
money on a higher level
I'm asking you for the answer it's a
question why is it that you can't you
have money I lost the money because I
did not have the knowledge that's what I
do like Ronnie so you don't have the
money to do it that's your answer
you ain't gotta turn up man this ain't
no [ __ ] show man not talking to us a
homey ain't no homey man because the
thing is the bottom line is man I
already got it on you like you ain't no
ain't no I'm gonna listen bro yo hold up
I gotta pee no hold up I'm matching
ain't no hold up I'm matching ain't no
holding what do you mean it ain't no
hold up man we here talking at civilized
people I'm trying to understand your
world because when I go to your concert
I'm curious about what you're saying I
don't know that's why I'm asking you the
questions well I'm explain to you oh you
ain't got to turn up on me man to man
dog [ __ ] these mics we could turn all
this
it off you ain't gotta do this it's cool
I love you bro but you ain't gonna turn
them in them don't try to embarrass us
I'm not trying to embarrass y'all what
I'm trying to say to y'all is this
industry of what I'm trying to get into
ain't nobody never broke down ain't
nobody broke down we all slaves so I
trying to disrespect you on your show we
all slaves a so much so yeah I try to
distract you period let me talk if
you're gonna have me talk we are slaves
we are slaves and y'all ain't
experienced nothing right here but a
moment from a movie out of glory